no I think if it's not natural it's not
organic you can't fool someone into
obligation if you do that it builds
resentment and that's like always a
control that's like mental abuse and
women complain about that all the time
and what I notice as well with the women
I know that's like that they're um
usually hypocritical there's double
standards they they can do that kind of
parent and say oh well he's not my child
if the father has one already but if we
do that it's a big problem this is where
this is what this is what I disagree
with yeah that's what but that's why men
like oftentimes don't get involved with
single moms because it's just it's too
confusing for them I'm allowed to do
this but not that and I'm taking on the
responsibility but I don't get any of
the authority and that's why a lot of
times they come out and say it's a bad
deal